six months ago a village went up in
Flames homes were lost families upended
and the nation got a stark warning about
our perilous climate future
but has anything changed have we heeded
the warning
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap and this week we're in
wennington the village in Essex just to
the east of London that was ravaged by
wildfire
it was the day last summer when the
Mercury hit 40 degrees for the first
time and I like many was watching the
television looking at pictures of this
place on fire and thinking so this is
England now not just California or
Portugal our settlements are now
threatened by extreme heat and the
danger of wildfire now six months on
we'll be meeting some of the residents
who fled the flames and also asking
whether we've done enough to prepare for
more Summers of extreme heat
and I've been talking to Chris Skidmore
the Tory Insider asked by the government
to review their carbon cutting plans
some thought he might water down the
ambition to meet Net Zero Turns out he's
called for tougher action
the false narrative that Net Zero is
some kind of green project or you know a
religion that's going to somehow make us
colder and poorer and what we found
actually is that Westminster Whitehall
are behind the curve but first remember
July the 19th last year fires on the
ground smoke in the air and potentially
deadly air temperatures let's meet those
affected to see how they're getting on
and also ask what's been done to adapt
to avoid others meeting the same fate
it was the most scariest day
that day was absolutely awful
kids
I've lost everything
you would never ever forget you in your
lifetime
for The Villages of Wellington it will
be hard to forget the summer of 2022 and
everything that was lost we had
Furniture in our TV down here
so all these Scotch marks on the ground
represent where stuff used to sit yeah
there was a ratchet and corner unit here
in a coffee table completely gone the
Flames spared most of Dave and Robbie's
home 19 nearby properties were
completely destroyed that somebody said
the Cottages are on a light and then
that's when we thought
no we were watching the fire creep along
the cottages and then the smoke started
coming out of our roof and we just went
it's gone the sense that it was such a
lottery is stuck
a few Cottages down Sophie and her
family were less fortunate so my house
is number four which was the White House
and what's happening to it today it's
been demolished today from the back
how do you feel devastated
it just didn't fit in a million years
that something like this would happen
how does it feel six months on
still awful really I mean especially as
we are still in a hostel
we got put in a hostel straight after
um and six months on we are still in a
hostel and the cats are not really doing
anything about it they've told us we've
got to stay in there for up to two years
where we used to look forward to the
Summers
they're gonna have a little bit of fear
behind them now because we've seen what
happened once and we'll all be living
here fear that it'll happen again
this needs to go to Parliament this
needs to be a compulsory order no do
what install fire breaks not just in
Wellington Village all over the country
it's the future the young people growing
up this is what they've got
there were over 24 000 wildfires in
England between June and August last
year more than four times the same
period in the previous year
as it happens Wellington has a fire
station in the village not that it
helped that day as the crews were
already out dousing Flames elsewhere
just as their whole station nearly went
up fire then effective defenses entered
the uh the grounds of the fire station
swept across this glass area here as you
can see got very close to our diesel
tank and the cruise worked extremely
hard and they stopped the fire literally
two foot from the diesel tank wow so
that that big tank of those full of
diesels yeah that's what 5000 liters of
diesel in there and what would happen if
that had gone definitely the station
would have been damaged we've got the
specious appliances in the background
there they would at least been damaged
or completely destroyed if if that
diesel tank had gone up so do we now
need to be aware that our Gardens could
be a Tinderbox and my crew's here at
Wendy's and fire station they're
producing a fire safety leaflet
obviously we do fire safety in the home
leaflets but we want to give information
to Residents about fire safety in the
garden this would include about keeping
your Hedges trimmed down taking away any
fire loading you know items in your
garden that you don't need make sure to
go to the correct recycling place old
gas cylinders that you don't need and
they even safe use of barbecues and
we've been showing that the the fire
breaks Within These Parks between the
houses and the country Park itself are
being looked at and are being put back
to a proper fire break to protect the
properties
the government told us they are working
on Wildfire risk plans and the forestry
Commission Now carries out vegetation
fire training do you think you've been
able to do enough to support the
residents one lady we've spoken to still
in a hostel not very happy we've been
here literally from the day of the fire
so we've been permanently down here
obviously immediately after the fire we
was down here almost almost 24 7. but
the support they've provided so far has
come at a cost of one hundred thousand
pounds and they've had to foot the whole
bill when we had the fires here
obviously all the work we did as a was a
cost to the council and we've actually
written to both the GLA and the
government for help and support and
sadly didn't come
the Village of Wellington and its 300
Souls have become a symbol for the
dangers of climate change and the scars
are not just on the buildings although
we are left
are laughable so I've got a little bit
of Survivor skill because all of our
friends in the rest of the block
I've got nothing global warming
everyone's talk about it it's not coming
it's here
is here and things need to be put in
place
on this I went to Westminster to catch
up with Chris Stark he's chief executive
of the climate change committee the
independent body that advises government
on how to combat and adapt to climate
change
where were you and what were you
thinking on July the 19th last year I
was on a train uh in the north of
England and it was a classic example of
the problems that come with high
temperatures because the trains uh air
conditioning field so I was in this
cooker essentially traveling through the
north England coming down from where I
live in Scotland to ironically see a
project that was about this challenge of
Net Zero so how you might generate
hydrogen so I kind of I suppose I was
kind of in the middle of several stories
about climate yeah and did you feel as
you were on that train kind of this is a
one-off or this is the shape of things
to come well sadly I did feel it was the
shape of things to come but I I think
everyone else on the tune thought it was
a way off and I think that's there's a
story in that that just I'm afraid the
kind of Summer that we had last year
is going to be a normal Summer by the
middle of the century increasingly it is
a normal event to have heat of that of
that of that you know that quite that
high high heat that we experience so we
need to get our heads around that which
is it's you know major major part of the
challenge you've done some reports about
adaptation which have been a little bit
critical of the slow progress tell me
where we are with that
well we have two challenges in climate
we have reducing emissions which gets
all the attention in in politics but the
other one is adaptation which is a
difficult word but it's how well we
adapt to the the risks that we we know
are there from climate change and I'm
afraid governments across the UK are
just not stepping up to that so we have
various plans for adaptation but they
don't really amount to hella beans give
me a few examples of what you'd like to
see well top of my list actually is
linked to the question of of overheating
and the heat that we face now every
summer and we need to think about what
we do with buildings so at last summer
during the heat wave we probably had 2
000 heat related deaths in this country
an astonishing figure we've seen that
before and that's from poorly ventilated
buildings that aren't prepared for that
kind of heat the kind of heat that you
might find commonly on on the continent
when you go on holidays the kind of
thing that we'll have here in London so
we need buildings that are well adapted
for that that would be the top of my my
list but just briefly about it I guess
you'd also say it's key that we don't
air condition our way out of that
problem because that's a climate calls
itself correct if we just install lots
of air conditioning units we actually
create a bigger problem which is higher
energy use and more heat in our cities
when from from all that air conditioning
use what we need is well-conditioned
buildings things like simple stuff like
Shutters on the outside of windows which
we don't commonly build what about the
actual fire risk because that was the
extraordinary thing I was looking at the
the Telly watching this in July thinking
hang on a minute this this is England
this is Britain this isn't Australia or
California
I was surprised too and of course I
shouldn't have been them you see with
welfare risk is now a big thing in the
North America and across Europe but it's
here in the UK as well I don't think
we've really start to Think Through the
the adaptation needs there we have to
think about things like fire breaks
we've got to think about what we do to
make sure that our buildings our Urban
connovations are well protected from
that kind of risk when it comes but it
comes by every year so the fire breaks
will actually be saying to landowners
that you mustn't put brush or basically
potential Tinder that close to buildings
is that the issue yes that's right that
kind of that kind of approach is
something that you don't see in common
practice but we'll need to think that
through properly in this country because
all our fire regulations and there are
lots and nearly all to do with the fire
risk from inside your home not from
Outsider I don't think we have a
regulatory environment that has really
thought through at all the fact that
welfare risk is now a very common
occurrence in this country and it will
get worse it's an important thing about
what climate change brings is it
intensifies these existing risks so the
kind of experience we had here in London
is the kind of experience I'm afraid
we're going to have every year so we've
got to prepare for that what would you
actually like government to do you know
there's some regulations or some laws
that need to be passed to make us as you
would say more resilient to these
extremes well there's not a simple
answer to that but it starts really with
the government taking seriously this
this challenge of climate change and
thinking through properly the change in
the climate that's coming next now in
the work that we've done we've looked at
two scenarios for an optimistic scenario
where the world warms by two degrees
centigrade and another scenario the
pessimistic scenario we're up close to
four degrees centigrade in that range is
the is the likely outcome I'm afraid and
we're not planning for that so across
the piece we need the government to pass
that through the lens of policy think
through what policies we would need for
that two to four degree world and start
putting policies around it
for more from Wellington and what it
might teach us about how to adapt to
climate change check out the latest
episode of the climate cast by scanning
the QR code on your screen right now and
I'll be back after the break with a
conversation with former energy Minister
Chris Skidmore who's just done a review
of our Net Zero policies and has some
tough things to say to the government
but first we've just got time to answer
one of your questions and it comes from
Lily she asks who determines what land
to destroy when building a solar farm
and is there an environmental impact
study done
thanks for the question Lily solar Farms
can degrade the environment but if done
well and in the right place they can
actually improve nature our research at
Lancaster shows that you can locate and
manage solar Farms to boost pollinators
potentially increasing crop yields
many people determine where solar Farms
are built the landowner has to agree and
developers have to apply for planning
permission and anyone can comment on a
planning application
the local planning committee who take
into account all the comments make the
final decision unless it's a very large
solar farm and then the planning
inspector which is part of central
government aside
several environmental documents required
for planning applications and soon every
development will need to show
biodiversity net gain which should
prevent any solar farm from destroying
the land
welcome back to Wellington where we
heard how residents suffered in last
year's wildfires and also housed a
nation the scant evidence we're adapting
to more extreme weather but while we all
boiled back then the conservative party
was consumed with a leadership race
where Net Zero became a political issue
so how did all of this I want you to
know how sad I am to be giving up the
best job in the world let me tell you a
story you have the numbers to make the
final two turn into this the climate
clock stops for no one after Liz truss
emerged Victorious from the upheaval of
the Tory leadership race she faced
pressure from the right of her party to
water down or even drop the UK's Net
Zero commitments in response former
energy Minister Chris Skidmore was asked
to review the country's Net Zero pledge
to make sure it was pro-business and
progress
[Music]
of course prime minister trust only
survived 44 days in Downing Street I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party but the review lived on the longer
we delay the narrower our choices to
deliver on net zero become and now prime
minister sunak has to deal with the
renewed call to go faster on Net Zero
with findings officially published I
caught up with the author conservative
MP Chris Skidmore
there is a false narrative that Net Zero
is some kind of green project you know a
religion that's going to somehow make us
colder and poorer and what we found
actually is that Westminster Whitehall
are behind the curve there are companies
and organizations particularly in
industrial areas you know in the North
and the Midlands who want to get on with
the job who see the international
opportunity of investing in Renewables
and clean technology in order to deliver
a profit margin give me some concrete
examples of what you've called for so
we've called for uh um 10 10-year
missions because one of the key
recommendations of the report also if
you want to do it in an affordable way
don't just get on with the job you've
got to plan ahead you've got to be able
to deliver and Implement Net Zero it's
no good having just the Targets in place
so we've said that we should have
missions on for instance solar on
onshore wind on nuclear on hydrogen well
let's set out a pathway we're just on
solo give me give me an example of what
you're calling for I think it's more on
buildings possibly Fields as well yes
I'm calling for a rooftop Revolution so
when it comes to solar it's the cheapest
way in which we can deliver on our
renewable commitments we've suggested 70
gigawatts of energy by uh 2035 should be
delivered how much do we have now on
Route 14 14.
it's five times yeah as much potentially
over 200 million extra panels that would
need to be installed in the UK onshore
wind onshore wind we come down in favor
of onshore wind we believe that the
obviously key to that is buying in local
consent so we're trying to come up with
new ways in which you can demonstrate
that communities can be paid back not
just in terms of pounds and Pence but
maybe you know buying inequity into the
project maybe being sort of purchasing
Community Halls oh it starts with
onshore wind is a question of making it
belong to the community making it feel
it's theirs rather than imposed from the
outside yeah absolutely and having that
sort of consent in place is critical to
Net Zero you know I'm not some kind of
like iconoclast who sort of devoutly
believes in Net Zero we've got to be
able to work with those individuals and
can communities who are concerned about
the transition and make sure that they
are aware that this is going to make
them warmer and richer and benefit the
local community not be detrimental what
about the grid because I often hear from
people who are trying to get renewable
energy projects off the ground that the
grid just isn't up to it is it and
that's absolutely right so grid grid
grid is a key message we've got this
sort of antiquated 1960s grid where we
see not just the lack of capacity on the
grid and the need to build Out Future
transmission lines there's a huge
waiting list there's delays there's
Community projects that are waiting for
2032 to get their grid slot
you're a a conservative you're an MP
that's standing down the next next
station in some ways you're an Insider
what are the chances of what you
recommend actually happening and I'm
also a pragmatist so when it comes to
the review we've made 129
recommendations in a 340 page report or
some of those recommendations are long
term by their very nature they need to
set out that mission-based path which is
why it's called permission zero but I've
also got a framework of 25 by 2025 25
key recommendations that I think the
government can do now get on with the
job and deliver in this Administration
so your fingers crossed that they could
actually take some of this on I think
we've seen you know a big shift over the
last couple of months so we've seen you
know an amendment go through that is
going to allow for onshore winds you
know subject to local consent we've seen
the moratorium of the actual ban on
fracking being restored I think things
are going in the right direction and you
know the UK government has done so much
over the past deliver on climate change
I just want to make sure they maintain
that momentum and remain global leaders
thanks very much Chris that's enough
questions from me but before I let you
go I've got a question from a viewer
Stuart Strath D who asked as part of our
q a how does what students are taught in
schools and colleges need to change to
ensure young people benefit from the
opportunities identified in your review
two when it comes to putting climate
into schools on the agenda on the
curriculum I know the government's
thinking about introducing a new climate
GCSE you know key priorities that
obviously looking at how we can develop
the skills so they can go into the
future green jobs that we need we need
about 400 000 new jobs so training for
those absolutely vital but I would say
also Rishi sunak has prioritized maths
actually when it comes to renewable
energy demonstrating to people that
energy that is renewable will make them
a saving a year on year on year as a
cumulative impact is really important so
I would say it's not just about teaching
climate it's also about teaching the
opportunities and the investment that
comes as a result of Net Zero
well as you can see I'm back in
Wellington now and I've been joined by
Sky's Science and Technology editor Tom
Clark actually to talk about some of the
stories away from here and what's been
happening this week it has actually been
an unusually mild winter across Europe
including the UK and that's had
interesting impacts with regard to gas
bills at a time of the Ukraine war yeah
absolutely yeah so despite the cold snap
we've had recently that we're having
right now in the UK it's been warm you
remember there were record high
temperatures through much of Central and
Eastern Europe through this winter as
well we've been incredibly lucky
considering how bad things could have
been given where gas prices are that's
absolutely right because there were
these forecasts you know given the
Ukraine war plus the fear of a cold
winter of astronomical gas prices and
that's what drove a lot of the fear in
the summer and the government policy to
put in these um put in a lot of help for
homes and businesses that's right
luckily they haven't got that high
wholesale prices are coming down now
bills are still astronomically high they
are they went up very very high through
the winter because of the impact of the
war in Ukraine and they're going to
remain high for a while but the latest
analysis from Engineers like Cornwall
insight for example predict that those
wholesale prices are going to fall
considerable they started falling over
anything in the fall considerably
through the year that is going to be a
big break now not directly for consumers
the average bill could still be close to
3 000 pounds by the summer but it is
quite good news for the government
because remember they had an energy
scheme to help support people beyond the
three thousand pound Energy bill so if
Bill's going to be below that that's
going to say the taxpayer a lot of money
indeed and that's going to be good news
for our wider economy there was talk of
tens of billions having to be put to
this and I guess those in the Treasure
will be quite relieved that might not
happen they will be enjoying the current
temperatures a lot I would predict yes
it is also the time of year when people
go to the Alps powerful Financial people
and other politicians to to Davos now
there's been a bit of a row there about
who's doing most are we doing enough
absolutely I mean normally this is where
yeah the global Elites go to enjoy the
skiing and sort of solve The World's
problems how they like to see it there's
something got a bit of a dressing down
actually the uh the U.S Secretary
General Antonio guterres went there and
he said this many times before but
warned them that they are really the
problem when it comes to solving the
problem of climate change the greatest
threat that he's ever seen in his
lifetime he says they've got a lot more
to do singled out fossil fuel companies
for not doing their part just quite
interesting there because we've heard a
lot about Finance becoming the Ally in
the fight against climate change not
there yet was that the message I I very
much think that is the message now
obviously lots of big powerful
investment companies hedge funds and the
banks signed up to commitments at the
Glasgow climate Summit uh said they were
going to do everything you know go
beyond but the ngos are of course in
Davos reminding them that so far they're
still investing far more in fossil fuel
projects than they are in the clean
economy is that your lot but one more
thing tiny bit of good news scientists
from the British Antarctic Survey using
satellite data have found a new Colony
event for penguins in Antarctica they're
very precious they you know they're
threatened by climate change they found
a new Colony a place they never knew
that before looking for guano deposits
they're dropping show up on the
satellite images against the snow and
there's about 500 more than we knew
before so that's great news love it
ending on a bit of bird poop who doesn't
like that tomclock thank you very much
indeed
well that's it from here in Wellington
which is probably a good job as the
lights begin to fade you can catch up
with the daily climate show weekdays at
3 30 and lots more climate news on the
website or Sky News app
[Music]